Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burn.
It's the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
March 18th,
2013 I it go and how are you?
I'm upstairs in my half a house at this point.
They got all the demolition done.
I'm going to have to open the fucking window cause it's already too hot in here.
As fucking thing needs to be replaced too.
Anybody want to buy a tree fort?
And I think that's what I bought.
I bought a tree fort with fucking Waldo Wall.
Look at the views.
If you see though the ILS,
all these fucking bullshit.
Everybody told me,
you know what?
If you ever go to buy a house,
this is what I suggest you do.
Walk in there wearing a helmet.
All right?
With some safety goggles on.
Put those fuckers,
put the whole ensemble on and then have one your biggest friends just grabbed
you like a battering ram and slam you into the wall of the house and have a look
around when you come,
when you come to have a look around,
you'll be surprised what you find in there.
All right.
If there's nothing in there other than the fucking horse.
Shit you just broke.
By all means make an offer on the house.
All right.
He's fucking cock sucking fucking insurance adjusters.
Oh,
well we'll cover over the fluke.
Do you know these dickheads?
I had like fucking wood in the walls.
Like those slats that they never have these constant,
they're gonna put plywood and then they're going to put dry wall over the top of
that and I'm just going to be like,
well that's the same thing isn't it?
Mr. Brewer was,
sorry you didn't have the premium coverage.
If you hand your premium coverage in,
we would if we would have paid for when your answer.
No,
you wouldn't know.
You would have found some other fucking reason not to pay me.
That's why you're in the big building,
isn't it?
Huh?
Why do you have a pinky ring?
How did you get that?
Is there some old woman in a wet house coat trying to figure out how to eat or
fucking Alto B?
Is that how you got that fucking ring?
You know it's funny.
It's,
the insurance adjuster hasn't even come over here yet.
And I've already been screaming at the windshield of my car because I know what
these fucking cops are going to do.
Yeah.
They did it to the entire city of New Orleans.
They're not going to do it to me.
You know,
I'm my own little city here.
I don't have any fucking,
you know,
there's no,
uh,
Sean Penn fucking rowing a boat up to my house coming to rescue me.
Is there,
you know,
I don't think Derris I'm on my own.
You know what?
That's fine.
I don't need any planning.
I've already resigned myself to the fact that I am going to fucking not only
restore this Goddamn fucking cock sucking fucking room.
Sorry guys.
Uh,
I'm in a mood here.
I am going to fucking,
I'm gonna make,
I'm gonna make it even better.
Okay?
That's what I'm doing.
I don't give a shit if I have to do standup gigs.
A and a,
I dunno,
one of those apartheid countries in front of a fucking dictator like Beyonce
did,
shaking her fucking perfectly round ass on New Year's Eve.
You think I'm above that?
I'll do.
I'll do what the fucking day.
Thanksgiving.
I'll give you a fucking a two for one.
You still are in flag day.
You can have me in a Hawaiian shirt and whatever fucking compounds you're living
in to keep the people from
storming the damn thing because you made a deal with the CIA and he gave away
the fucking oil,
didn't ya?
I'll come down there.
I'll do my act and your fucking,
all right,
I'm going to get some of that blood money.
I'm gonna get some of that blood money and I'm going to fucking restore this God
damn Rome back to the way it was supposed to be.
You know,
cause that's what the fuck I've been doing.
I've been sitting here for the last fucking couple of days and I've been finding
out where all the God damn stuff is that I need.
Have I cursed enough?
I really got to take this down a notch,
don't I?
Or does it make you feel better about yourself?
These words,
we have more than I do.
She had no,
I'm a fucking moron.
I know I'll never pass.
Nothing,
you know,
your Mike,
Somebody in their log.
You know,
I was good at math,
but I wouldn't do good in history.
Well I like,
I was good and half,
but I wasn't good with that woodwork and stuff shit.
Right.
I'm one of them mother fuckers,
minimum few mother fuckers.
I ain't going to shit.
I shucked from the second I pulled into the parking lot,
the shit,
she called my name and I forget what the fuck she was talking about,
you know,
and he'd be,
she just be like,
let it and I'll be locked.
Just shit in there.
You know,
just sitting there wondering why my deck was hard,
you know.
Um,
am I having a nervous breakdown?
Oh,
Christ.
So I was looking,
I forgot to look this shit up.
God dammit.
So I've been looking up all these old houses that they have out here in Los
Angeles,
by the way,
specifically the Pasadena area has these amazing houses out there.
Um,
and I've just been looking up how people went about restoring them when they
came.
And now if they were able to fucking restore an entire Goddamn,
um,
house,
I,
there has to be enough shit left for me to do a room.
Right.
Please tell me that just sounded like fast Eddie and fucking a reservoir dogs.
Please tell me.
Tell somebody got the diamonds.
Okay.
Can someone just please fucking tell me.
So anyways,
I started looking up all these houses,
right?
And this is back,
you know,
back in the day,
I'm a big fan of fucking blue blood money when there was a name attached to it,
you know,
back in the day,
like people knew the names of the rich that was stealing from him.
They knew what they looked like,
they knew where they lived.
It was unreal.
The Vanderbilts,
the Astors,
the Rockefellers,
the Rothschilds,
you know,
and then you had the people who started,
uh,
you know,
like,
like proctor and gamble,
that wasn't just a name.
Those were fucking people.
Like there's a house out in Pasadena called the gamble house,
and it was made by these guys,
green and green.
And they did those,
uh,
what do you call them?
Uh,
uh,
what do you call craftsman?
American craftsman houses.
So they would build a house farm and everybody,
we bought it.
How much money do you think Procter and gamble having you drive by?
Well,
there's the gamble house right there.
That's gambles house.
What is fucking proctors look like?
You know,
Johnson and Johnson,
all those goddamn families.
So anyways,
so it was looking these things up.
And this is house out in Pasadena called the blacker house.
The Robert are blacker house.
And uh,
what,
uh,
come on.
You fuck it.
I can't,
you know something how dumb I am.
I can't even click on something.
Hang on a second area doesn't make click on this shit.
The Blacker House out in Pasadena,
you can't believe what happened.
This house is fucking unbelievable.
Actually drove by it the other day,
like a goddamn stalker looking at it.
And um,
this house was made,
I guess for this guy,
Robert and Nelly blacker.
Right?
So typical,
you know,
rich people,
they get just unfucking believable house,
you know,
built at the turn of the last century.
So it's all this would,
you know,
they cut down like fucking 150 200 year old trees or whatever.
So the shit solid as a rock,
you know,
as opposed to that fucking bullshit they got down at home depot,
fucking shits grown down in El Salvador by some fucking eight year old.
You know,
once the tree is taller than the kid,
they make the kids shot down four in the morning before they make them fucking
plan another one,
start watering it.
You know,
you don't realize that that's how trees grow now.
Eight year olds,
they teach them how to sleep on their feet.
They sleep like standing up and they sit there like just slowly watering them
all night and then it causes them to grow faster.
It's a whole,
it's a whole law.
I saw him on 60 minutes.
You guys should check it out if you get a chance.
We got a Hulu,
you might want to look that up.
But anyways,
so they made this amazing house and all the furniture and all the shit in it and
the chandelier's and all of that are basically worth a small fortune now.
So what happened is of course the fucking lady outlives the guy.
Why?
Because when shit hits the fan,
women cry and guys fucking deal with it.
That's why bang,
there it is.
Did the bell go off in your head?
That's the first sexist,
more ronic thing that I'm going to sit,
well,
not first moronic,
but the first moronically sexist thing that I'm going to say in this fucking
podcast.
All right?
When the shit hits the fan,
the ladies,
they fucking cry.
That's what they do.
The guys were crying on the inside,
but we got to hold that shit together as we push an Ikea couch under the fucking
waterfall that's coming through your top of your house.
That's,
that's what we do.
They go,
oh my God,
if you knew it,
it happened with EA and they get it out.
We don't.
So hence 35 fucking years later,
we drop of a heart attack while mowing the lawn because in the middle of our
chest,
but more,
it's still fucking in there.
Attached to,
yeah.
Oh my God.
The car is against that.
All that fucking shit is just one big fucking ball sitting there.
Right on top of your heart.
And then that's it.
You fucking kill over.
And then she has the nerve to stand there.
Go.
And I told him to stop eating red meat.
I told him to have his salad.
He didn't like it.
He said that food was for the Queens.
Um,
anyways,
so this fucking house,
this fucking house,
um,
they kept everything like all original,
right up until the forties.
So that stuff was already 40 years old.
They already weren't making furniture.
Well,
maybe the forties,
they kind of still,
but the style had changed.
So if you walked into that house in mid,
like 1945 when this woman died,
it was like stepping back in time,
like 45 years I gave ever go into an old person's house,
you see this stereo.
If they kept it in immaculate,
immaculate condition.
The car they're driving,
their fucking can opener.
Well maybe not now,
but back in the day then old can opener.
You know,
he made us some real fucking materials and set us on plastic hunk of Shit,
right?
They had all that stuff and they had all those beautiful sconces and not the
chandelier's and all that stuff on,
on,
on the,
on the walls and on the sealant,
everything.
Right.
So anyways,
in the wealth,
the Lei says,
whoever buys this house,
it's,
it's all encompassing.
You have to buy the house.
It comes with all the furniture.
They had a look what it looks like.
Another house behind it.
That was just for visitors.
Like a mother in law suite look like a fucking four bedroom colonial.
That was the guest house.
That's how big this fucking house was.
They had a greenhouse.
They had this giant property.
So when you went in and bought it,
after she died,
the person had to buy everything and it wasn't allowed to sell off anything.
So course she dies and then the fucking greedy cuts.
What do they do?
They sell the house and then that person immediately divides it up,
sells off the mother in law suite,
gets rid of the greenhouse,
cuts up the fucking property,
has an infamous fucking yard sale and sells all of this unbelievable furniture.
And to this day it's in museums and private collectors own the shit gets even
worse.
What happened to this fucking house?
It's what makes me feel better about me cause I only lost one room.
It's beautiful fucking house with all the shit.
They already lost all the furniture,
right?
But they still have to do the windows and the chandeliers and all that shit.
Some cut buys it in 1985 who's a fucking deals in like vintage chandeliers and
all this stuff.
He buys the house for 1 million bucks.
Guts.
The fucking thing is selling these chandeliers for like six figures to who?
I don't know,
but some are we selling them for like 150 200 grand.
He selling the sconces for like a hundred grand.
He guts.
The fucking place replaces everything with the home depot replica piece of shit
was called the rape of the other fucking blacker house or whatever.
I'm reading all of this stuff.
Is this boring for you?
I don't know what.
So I've been reading up on all of this ship or whatever.
Somebody bought the house after and was able to restore it painstakingly.
I made add painstakingly.
So I figured if these guys can do that,
you know,
I can,
I can restore this one fucking run there.
Right.
Trying to pull this shit on me telling me that people don't put plaster up
anymore.
It's like,
yeah,
they do.
I just had my fucking rooms out there.
Replastered I already have a guy.
I write your fucking cunt with your plywood and your dry wall.
Is that what you're going to do then?
Why don't I just do it?
Why don't I just fucking do it?
Because you'd fuck it up,
Bill.
Yeah.
But you know what?
I could do most of it around the windows will be a little bit difficult because
it requires some fucking measurements.
Um,
so anyways,
that has been,
uh,
that's been my week and
I got a bunch of Shit I have to do tomorrow,
right?
So that's why I'm doing the podcast here Sunday afternoon.
So anyways,
I walk into the living room,
the lovely Neal is watching one of reality shows and you know,
it's the five just toxic women sitting in this limousine and one of these women
is talent.
This hap,
one of these women who is divorced is telling this happily married woman that
she needs to speak up to her husband more.
And it was basically because the husband said,
I'm old fashioned.
He goes,
I'm an old fashioned guy.
So he's out there killing it,
making an insane fucking living,
right?
And she's the little homemaker,
So Kentucky,
Mick divorce thing,
right?
Contact,
divorce stain.
There you go.
It's sitting in the back of the limo and basically telling the girl who's
fucking,
she's got the best deal ever.
She married somebody who's out there making a fuck load of money and all she's
got to do is keep the house together.
So are you gonna do you got all fucking day?
Jesus Christ.
How long does it take to sweep the kitchen?
Yup.
You can even hire a fucking cleaning company just to have the shit clean.
And when I come home,
have dinner ready for the life of me,
for the life of me.
I don't know why certain people look at that as slavery,
you know?
Unless look,
if you have some fucking dream,
you know,
and you have ideas and that type of thing that you want to go out and pursue
them,
by all means.
But if you're just going to be another cog in the wheel
bump,
taking the fucking subway to work to go make somebody else's dream come true.
You know what I mean?
Why the fuck would you take that other thing you got all day to get out of the
house?
Go for a fucking walk.
You know,
dude,
I swear to God in another life,
if I'm a fucking stay at home mother,
I swear to fucking God.
I am going to,
I'm going to get fucking season tickets,
okay
to everything to fucking all four sports and I'm going to knock out everything I
have to do during the day.
I'm going to have that fucking dinner ready the second the dude comes in and
then when it's over,
see Ya.
I'm out fucking run it down the thing on my fucking heels and I'll go to the God
damn game.
I don't know what they're complaining about.
You couldn't have more fucking free time.
You know,
even when you have kids,
it's,
you're still running shit.
You're still the boss.
You know.
I Dunno.
I know I've talked about this shit.
So she ends up telling this,
this,
this lady in the fucking back of this limo.
She's like,
you know,
that's all well and good if he wants to fuck and blah blah blah.
But you know that old fashioned stuff can also be controlling.
It can outsell beat control.
It can.
You know,
people when people are dumb is when they make one point and they have to say it
three times in a fucking row to make it sound like they made a bunch of
different points,
but they only made one.
Yeah.
And now it's not working and now it's there where I can
do that shit.
You just want to slap them on the side of the head.
It's like,
are you stuck in there?
What's wrong with you?
I heard you the first time I heard you the first time.
She fucking driving me fucking nuts with this shit.
And then she ends it with,
you know,
so if he wants a sandwich,
he should go out there and have to make it himself.
And I just ah,
oh that whole fucking shit I women like that are always like,
you're not the king.
You're not the king.
But then two seconds later if you were to say you're a queen,
they would 100% agree with you.
And it's that classic shit.
I think I did it in one of my standup things on stand up skittles.
I swear to fucking God.
Every God damn thing that they bitch about that they do not want to be done to
them.
They will fucking duty you in a second if you let them.
All right.
Okay.
This is why it,
me and Nia can't watch TV together because she watches the dumb whore channel
and she watches it to laugh at the dumb horse,
which if I was a woman,
I could sit there and laugh at the dumb horse because at no point would I be
financially like connecting,
you know what I mean?
Like the biggest fear for me anyways is you're going to fucking get married.
The is going to flip on you and then take everything it got and there's nothing
he can fucking do about it.
Right.
So when I watched those stupid horse,
that's what I see.
I see a limo full of child support,
just fucking lazy.
Get your fucking life together.
Losers decked out.
By the way.
They were on their way to a titty bar.
Okay.
You know,
so right to everybody.
And if everybody in the car is fucking suspect,
it's like,
wait,
w w what the fuck?
How old are you?
I don't even go to the titty bars anymore,
but Christ think ladies,
get your middle aged pussies back in the fucking house and make a God damn
sandwich.
Am I right?
Do you know bad?
I want to go on like Ellen Degeneres show and somehow get half of that out
just to see how long,
how much of it I could get out
before,
I don't know,
before somebody was through the morning after pill at me.
I'm a viola.
That shit right in my giant forehead.
Um,
anyways,
I was just thinking,
what if my hitting me in the forehead was a carnival game?
What we,
what do you think you would win?
It would be so fucking easy.
My forehead.
So God damn big.
You know,
you'd win one of those.
Remember those little Koalas that the could stick on the end of your pencil back
in the 70s.
I'm sure they got a box of those leftovers somewhere.
That's what you'd win until they ran out.
So anyways,
this is the Monday morning podcast.
Everybody,
it's ignorant.
It's sexist and uh,
it's great for kids.
Uh,
we got some advertising.
Everybody.
We only got one this week.
Oh,
we only got one.
Strap yourselves in IR.
We go stamps.com everybody a quick trip to the post office is hardly ever quick
driving.
They're finding parking,
you know,
trying to get there before they close,
right?
You go to stick it in the [inaudible] in the mailbox.
You freak out is everything.
Got The stamps on it and all,
all that crap,
right?
It's a hassle.
So do what I do.
You stamps.com instead,
stamps.com is quick and eat is the quick and easy way to get postage on demand
for any business.
Buy and print official US postage for any letter or package using your own
computer and printer stamps.com we'll even send you a digital scale that
calculates the exact postage you need for any class of mail.
You don't need one of those expensive postage meters and you'll never waste
valuable time making trips to the post office.
Again,
endorsement,
this is me,
everybody.
I use stamps.com to send my DVDs out to my wonderful standup gigs.
I have never had a problem.
It's phenomenal.
I've done it.
My underwear,
I've done it with no shirt on.
Where in my,
my uh,
my little Janes is something right looking like I'm going to be on the cover of
some teen beat magazine,
like the,
the sensation Joe to Rosa Tri stamps.com today.
Right now use my last name bur bur for a special offer,
no risk trial plus a $110 bonus offer that includes a digital scale and up to
$55 free postage.
They given you 55 bucks.
Don't wait.
Go to stamps.com before you do anything else,
click on the microphone at the top of the homepage and type in burpee.
You rr that stamps.com enter burr.
All right,
back to the podcast,
back to the podcast.
Um,
did you guys watch the uh,
the UFC fight?
Um,
GSP versus Nick Diaz?
I believe his name was nick.
I go in and out of watching the UFC.
I,
I love it.
I love the UFC.
I love boxing.
I love all that stuff.
It's just that all the pay per views,
our Saturday night am I right,
the Saturday night and I'm usually doing shows and uh,
and I missed them.
I always ended up missing him.
And um,
but every once in a while what happens is like I used to watch it on the versus
network all the time and uh,
I don't give a fuck.
You know what level UFC that is?
It's two people trying to beat the shit out of each other.
Then a way better fighting than I am.
Like,
I'm not going to watch that.
What am I going to watch five whores and the back of a limo on the way to a
titty bar talking about how they don't want to make a fucking sandwich,
you know?
Well,
they get your ass on this stage,
sweetheart.
Oh,
that's the third sexist neurotic one.
Um,
ah,
God,
that fucking dead girl really annoyed me.
That woman was happy.
She was making sandwiches and this girl is such a fucking negative cunt.
It's not enough that she's fucked up around relationship.
She has stuff.
Fuck this girl's relationship and ruin.
This guy's thought he's going to,
he's going to come home and be like,
what the fuck happened?
Everything was going great.
And then she's going to come at him with an attitude,
you know,
not bringing two nickels into the fucking relationship,
you know?
I Dunno.
All right,
let's,
let's just let it go.
Bill.
Let's just fucking let it go.
I mean,
I don't know,
maybe,
maybe she's making millions on her reality show.
I can tell you right now,
they probably make less than comedians.
Let me ask you this,
people,
when was the last time you bought a box set?
Um,
of a reality show?
I don't think they exist.
That's why they like disposable.
That's like the bic lighter of fucking television shows.
Um,
it doesn't have any legs,
you know,
so they pay you once
pay once and they pay us shit money.
Yeah.
You know what good.
And I'm glad they're all getting fucked.
Spending all their money on fucking Manny Petty's.
Um,
Jesus Christ.
Is this,
what,
am I really that upset about a reality show or is it the fact that half of my
hubs is fucking gutted right now?
Couldn't even say house have my hus anyways.
So every once in a while,
this is the thing for me.
I am a sucker for a boxing or a UFC promo.
You know,
when they get on there and they do the background,
they show both the fighters working out and they start telling their stories and
everything that they have on the line and how they need to,
I swear to God,
if I start watching one of those fucking things,
I'm ordering the fight to the point.
Like I avoid them.
I avoid them because so many times you fucking order them and then the fight
sucks.
You know,
it doesn't live up to the hype,
you know,
especially with boxing.
Jesus fucking Christ Jesus Christ.
I've spent more fucking money on all the way back to the Tyson error.
The Tyson ones were always worth their money even though he'd knock them out and
fucking 90 seconds.
But it was still like you were watching some Babe Ruth Shit in new it.
You know,
they only went into the Lennox Lewis years and it just got all fucked up.
Even half the Oscar de la Hoya once towards the end I got fucked on those,
you know,
and then they always got that great white hope coming in,
and they show him,
Hey Heidi,
Heidi,
Hawaii,
Heidi who write and he's skipping rope and he's got an angry fucking look on his
face.
You look at him,
go at least got kicked the shit out of me.
Right?
And then the black guys all confident,
like damn ain't sweating them up.
And you're like,
you know what,
I'm going to order this shit and what comes out.
Oh did he tell you to take?
And that's it.
Just fucking over.
It's fucking over.
You know,
he wasn't fast enough.
it was too slow.
Yeah,
know it,
but they got you.
They fucking hype the shit up and the fucking dude sat there.
Not only did it beat his ass,
he did a little dance mocking him and then he just knocked him the fuck out.
That's what happens every God damn time.
Right.
But I still order it.
So the UFC thing,
like you're upstream Jeremy Law.
So I fucking watch,
I'm watching Dana White on there,
right?
And Dana white comes to the podium and I'm going,
Bill,
don't watch this fucking promo.
Do not watch this promo because the second you're done watching this,
you're going to take 50 60 bucks,
whatever it is.
And it's going out the window.
But there was something about the look on Dana White's face.
I'm like,
I got to watch this shit.
And he comes to the mic,
you know,
just a Mike and he's just like,
GSP
snapped today.
It is the most angry I've ever seen him.
He said,
Nick Diaz is the most disrespectful human being on the planet and he is going to
absolutely destroy him.
Something like that.
Okay.
And I'm thinking like,
GSP,
this guy's like the fuck.
He's like Captain America.
He never gets mad at anybody.
He doesn't let anybody get under his skin.
He fucking stage.
He's like a robot.
He just fucking goes in and does what he's got to do.
He's made them that man.
And then I see this Nick Diaz Guy and he just looked,
he just looks the part like,
fuck you bitch,
I'll fuck you up.
And it was just the two worlds.
The guy who spikes the football and the guy would just cans it to the referee
colliding.
I got to see this shit.
I want to see what a furious fucking GSP looks like and I want to see if this
other guy can actually back up all this shit talk.
And so I ordered the fucking fight.
Okay.
It ends up being a great fight.
I'm not saying then I got fucked on this fight at all.
It's totally worth it.
And the fight before,
it was great with that dude from Texas with the heavy hands and the fucking
Ulysses s grant beard loved it.
Okay.
But this is what pissed me off at the fucking end of it and made me feel stupid.
Was it in the end,
you know,
Rogan interview when the guy and then they won't.
And he was going,
you know,
you seem like you got really angry and blah,
blah,
blah.
And then he just goes,
uh,
you know,
and I was waiting for him to be like saying like,
this guy is a piece of shit and I'm glad I fucking beat him.
And I was waiting for him to finally see that side of him.
And,
and he just goes a GSP just like I did not take anything.
He says he has a great fighter.
He did a great job promoting the fight.
Everybody give him a round of applause.
He is,
he is the stairs that but guy,
it's like,
wait a minute,
I thought you snapped.
I thought you did take it personal.
I might have fucking stupid.
I felt like a fucking idiot.
I did not take,
I pause.
It's like George,
however you say his name,
the whole reason I fucking ordered the fight was because I thought you took it
personally.
I'm an idiot.
I'm like Charlie Brown trying to kick the football.
I fall for it every fucking talk right now.
Maybe it's because he won.
Well,
maybe because he's so aware of his,
his image that he just didn't let on that the guy annoyed the shit out of him.
But there's fucking sitting there.
Yeah.
Holding each others arms up by man,
you know,
and it just,
I dunno,
he absolutely snapped today.
Fast forward,
I did not take it personally.
He has a great guy come over here.
Uh,
we are gonna go play shuffleboard now.
Here's a great guy.
He is a good competitor.
And uh,
and then the other guys going like,
Hey,
I think I'm done with that.
The MMA of die.
You know,
I'm sick of this.
I don't know what to do now.
And then George,
isn't it background?
No,
no,
no.
Stick with it.
You can de Yoga come back.
He's like giving them words of encouragement.
I Dunno.
Am I an idiot?
But I that,
that fucking annoyed me.
Don't fucking tell me this guy's taking it personally.
And then I ordered the fight and then the fucking guy said he wasn't,
it's false advertising.
I'm just fucking around was a great fight.
But you know what I mean?
Don't look,
I know that just sell on the fight,
but don't fucking tell me that
everything we sat up until this point was bullshit.
I'm actually friends with him and his wife.
We got down to Applebee's every other day.
We do not take it personally.
Um,
whatever.
I was still a great fight and uh,
you know,
I gotta keep saying that in case I fucking run into one of those guys and they
headbutt me with their fucking cauliflower to elect their ears.
Even their ears are tough,
you know,
every time I watch a UFC event,
you know what it is,
it's the fucking kicks.
That's what kills me is amazing as it is to watch somebody who's on the bottom
getting fucking taken elbows to the head and,
and fucking actually looking over at the clock like,
oh,
17 more seconds to this.
I can handle it.
Maybe if I bring my bloody forehead closer to his chest,
um,
he will only maybe grazed the back of my head and you know,
I have fresh skin back there that hasn't been broken wide open at this point.
Like the level of toughness is that is that,
that's a whole nother level.
But when they're just standing up and the fucking one dude just kicks the other
dude right where you'd get a Charlie horse and they just take it,
that fucking blows.
Like how do you,
how do you get that tough dude?
I'm telling right now if I was standing in line at a fucking grocery store and
some eight year old had pants on and some eight year old came up to me and just
fucking whack me,
punched me and I maybe not punch,
I could take a punch from an eight year old.
All right,
let,
let's,
let's move it up here of fucked in an eight year old whose dad is like 609 so
the kids already five fucking four.
I'm just saying any,
if you ever want to just fucking knock me down.
You don't have to be all fancy and hit me in the judge.
Just hit me in the leg right there.
I will crumple like the fucking plaster in the ceiling of my office.
Um,
everything just goes back to that,
doesn't it?
Um,
what else?
What else can we talk about here?
I'll be,
we talk hockey.
Did anybody watched the Bruins Pans Game Penguin's game?
They put on a fucking four checking clinic.
They uh,
they were amazing.
They look great in the fact that Gino isn't even back yet was uh,
was pretty scary.
I mean we have a great defense so we were able to keep it two to one,
but it felt like it was more like three,
three,
one like a back in the day three,
one,
three.
One was like the tipping point because then if you went down by three goals,
it was fucking over.
There was no way you would come back.
Then they got rid of the red line and then,
you know,
within a minute it's like a Thai fucking score.
But um,
they look great.
And Crosby is without a doubt,
the best player in the fucking league.
It's insane.
That fucking line that they have is terrifying.
And a,
the only thing I'd say is there maybe their goal tending,
I guess it's,
they're starting to play better,
but I don't know about that goal tending.
I Dunno either way.
Either way.
They beat us again.
We finally beat the capital's.
That was cool.
But we,
we're,
we're missing a Crosby level now.
Fuck.
Nobody's across Crosby's level.
But you know,
we need a fucking 50 potential 50 goal score and guy,
um,
we need,
we need a next level guy.
We got a defense.
That's all good.
We got the goal tending.
But like this whole shit,
what we're going to score two fucking goals a game and try to stop these upper
echelon teams.
It's just,
it's not working.
It's not fucking where,
you know what's great than anybody watched the capitals game course you did.
Did you see when that,
that dude was at Henderson and something got kicked out?
Whatever the fuck his name is,
he gets kicked out of the game and some Boston Bruins fan is down at him to the
point the guy stops and starts yelling back at him.
You gotta see I gotta Oh,
did I erase?
I think I erased it.
If anybody's got a copy of it.
It's a fight about,
was like five minutes left in the game.
And one of the capitals gets taken off the ice.
I was at the end of the second period.
I don't fucking,
all you do is you got to see the,
the bouncer,
the security guy who's in,
in like the tunnel.
And he fucking comes walking out and just clear as day.
He starts pointing at the Bruins fan and he goes,
Hey,
shut your fucking mouth.
Shut your fucking,
and then they,
they cut it.
I love it.
I love seeing highlights of where I'm from and seeing the behavior hasn't
changed.
It makes me feel smart.
Um,
all right,
let's get to some,
um,
emails for the week.
Now a lot of you guys always ask me,
and I always forget to say,
you know,
if you want to email the podcast,
you want to ask me questions?
You want to trash me?
You want to do whatever the hell you want to do.
Uh,
it's bill at the [inaudible] podcast.com bill at the capital m,
capital m,
capital p Ahd cast a.com.
Um,
all right.
Army wife relocation a,
their bill.
I hope your house is feeling better.
Thank you.
Yeah,
it's actually,
it's been gutted.
It's been gutted at this point.
That's where we're at.
Um,
hope you house is feeling better.
I am an army wife currently living in but fucking Berg cans,
ass.
We are stationed at Fort Reilly until July this year.
When my sweetheart heads over,
heads on over to Afghanistan.
My conundrum is where should I move when he leaves because I sure as hell ain't
stay in here by myself at any moment or heard of fat,
dirty pajam bottom wearing Walmart shoppers with black bottom feet.
Jay's is,
can you paint a picture?
Um,
said could lynch me for being Brown and under 300 pounds.
I got to get Outta here and thankfully I am fortunate to have two choices of
where to go in there in lies.
The reason that I need your assistance.
Um,
I could move back to Seattle where I live two years ago.
It's all true about Seattle by the way.
Beautiful,
clean white,
depressing reigny better than Kansas or I could go to Fort Lauderdale,
Florida where I have never lived,
but I just visited last week.
It's a little scary because I haven't driven like a complete retard with crystal
meth throwing through my veins.
So I don't know if I can handle myself on the road.
But aside from that,
it's got just as much going on going from me.
There is Seattle and it's not fucking Kansas.
Uh,
I think that with all your travels,
you must have some insight that you could really,
you could relay loudly to me through your podcast.
Um,
if I,
well personally
I would pick Seattle over Fort Lauderdale,
Florida,
any day of the fucking week when people are smarter.
Um,
okay.
You don't have the hurricanes
like Florida is like a destination state for dark bags.
You know what I mean?
Okay.
It's,
it's one of those,
like La is a destination city for people like me.
You know,
I'm going to be a movie star,
whatever dumb shit we want to do,
right?
So we come out here,
you know,
and then bitch about how flaky everybody is and when the reality is,
it's us.
You know,
we're the ones coming out here and we don't,
we're not personally invested.
Nobody's invested in this fucking city.
Um,
cause you always think I'm gonna make my money,
then I'm going to get the fuck outta here.
That's in everybody's trying to make the money.
So it always looking over everybody's shoulder,
trying to see the next person coming in the fucking room and a while they say
everybody out here is flaky.
But anyways,
getting back to what you were talking about,
I would go to,
let me,
Seattle,
Seattle is fucking beautiful.
I know it rains.
I know it's fucking depressing.
But um,
Fort Lauderdale,
I don't know man.
I mean
the fact that it's like,
it don't just let people go down there for spring break.
Do you want that for like one month of your year?
You know,
waking up in the morning here and show show yard tense.
Do you want to do,
you don't want to do that.
You know,
you got fucking hurricanes.
There's alligators.
They got my Skeeto size in my fucking head.
Um,
I dunno.
I mean,
you know,
you don't understand.
All I do is I fly in and I do a fucking gig down here,
like the Strip mall area.
And like,
I dunno,
I like the Tampa Bay lightning and I like the devil race.
I Dunno.
Like Florida is,
is,
is kind of like Sunny Kansas in a way.
You kind of still got the gun culture.
You kind of still got the Walmart people.
Um,
I'm not saying they're all like dead,
you know what I mean?
I mean,
tiger woods lives there,
right?
Jack has a place down there,
some zillionaires down and he got,
you got the fucking all the movie stars living down there in Miami,
but Fort Lauderdale.
Um,
I dunno,
that's safe to say cause I don't fucking play there and I play Seattle.
So I think I made a smart business move there.
Firstly,
I would move to Seattle.
Yeah.
Fuck damn moved to Seattle.
Go down of the fish mark and get yourself a fucking clam sandwich.
Whatever the fuck you do.
I don't know.
I,
you know,
I dunno.
I don't fucking know.
You got like on the other opposite ends of the spectrum.
Listen,
will you unbelievably depressed.
If it's cloudy fucking nine months out of the year,
then I wouldn't move there.
But I'm just letting you know,
I saw a t shirt,
one of the few really truly funny tee shirts when I was in Florida.
It said Florida,
a sunny place for shady people.
You know,
it's Kinda like,
you know,
Florida is the Sunny Alaska,
I guess is what I should call it,
where there's a lot of people in Alaska who have some unfinished business down
here in the lower 48 if you know what I mean.
Wink,
wink,
a little slap of the nose there.
All right.
There's a lot of people,
la running from things,
you know.
Okay.
If the skaters don't get them,
then the gators wheel.
What fucking song was that?
That just popped in my head.
Yeah.
Hang down your head.
Tom Dooley.
Was that the one?
Hang down your head and Kai [inaudible] hang on.
I wasn't really,
oh boy.
You're bound to died.
That's funny.
Back then you could have like a hit song just talking about somebody who killed
a woman and I got hung.
I met her on the metal tin.
Yeah,
blah,
blah.
Bloom.
Met her around the mouth pin,
stabbed her with Myra.
Man.
Okay.
I hang down your head,
Tom Dooley.
That's a song about a hang down your head.
You know,
like,
I'm supposed to feel bad for Tom Dooley.
It's like you fucking killed.
You killed your girlfriend.
Yeah.
Go Fuck Yourself Tom.
Um,
alright.
Addicted to vagina.
The next one.
Everybody.
How's it going?
The,
it'd be like,
boy,
I'm 22 year old college student.
You're not addicted to vagina.
You're a 22 year old college student.
You're doing what you should be doing.
You don't have an addiction.
All right?
Okay.
Uh,
what are you,
you're sowing your oats,
whatever the fuck they say.
Um,
I've been seeing this girl for a while.
Nothing serious,
but we've been hooking up on and off for about a year.
All right,
so you've got a side piece.
Nothing wrong with that.
Um,
she's incredible looking.
What the hell?
I,
she has the natural body of a playboy model.
She's the kind of girl who doesn't need makeup.
You're going to keep saying the same thing over and over again.
I'm jealous you son of a bitch.
Um,
she has long,
blonde hair and she's the most amazing fuck that can possibly exist.
Uh,
this is the curse of a guy.
However,
I want to fuck somebody else.
Right?
She's ferocious in bed.
What did she growled at your balls?
Easy Lady Ac.
Um,
and for some reason she thinks we're in the same league.
He goes,
but I hate her.
I hate everything about her.
Every contrived opinion that falls out of her soft,
perfect lips.
Every shitty band she tries to get me to listen to every unfunny air quote joke.
She insist on repeating over and over and over every going to know where stories
she spends five hours telling me I hate her.
Oh my God.
Uh,
but I just keep agreeing to,
to see her.
I've manned up and stopped replying to her text messages a few times now and
blocked her on Facebook.
But before long she'll send me a text about some nonsense.
The blood will start rushing to my cock and all of a sudden I'm standing next to
her again.
It's like a compulsion.
I feel like a heroin addict.
I get laid,
but fucking other girls just feels like drinking non alcoholic beer at this
point.
Can I just stop and say a lot of you guys are really good writers like that.
Kansas one was really written really well.
This was great.
Like I would,
it's just be,
should be in reader's digest.
They would fuck him,
you know,
loosen the belt a little.
Um,
anyways,
what do I do man up and suppress my instincts,
throw her out the bedroom window or quit cold Turkey.
Um,
I never missed a podcast.
We'll love to go see you do a Gig in Ireland.
Go Fuck Yourself.
Um,
okay.
What do you do?
Uh,
uh,
you know what I was,
I've never been able to solve that problem,
you know,
because unless you just jerked off,
you know she's going to text you and it's just gonna it's going to be a layup.
And she's like,
guys can't say no to lay up pussy.
We just can't,
you know,
unless way like head over heels in love.
Yeah.
And like,
yeah,
I guess,
when you meet the right one then he could say no,
but you know what?
It still pisses you off.
Yeah.
Fucking annoys you.
You know why?
Cause like when you're with the person who's supposed to be with and then
somebody throws you a little something and it could fucking happen and you don't
fucking do it.
You come home and you want to get credit for it.
And women go,
why should you get credit for something that you should be doing?
And it's like,
you know what?
Go Fuck Yourself.
That's why.
Because you're not me.
You're not a guy.
And we are literally were designed
to fucking be weak.
So we will fuck you so we could get out of the cave so he could fucking
progress.
So we would procreate.
We or I,
we are wired,
wired
to fuck.
This is such a moronic fucker.
Podcasts.
I love it.
Um,
all right,
so what should you do?
All right,
well ultimately in life,
what do you want to be married to the woman or your dreams or some girl who's
ferocious in bed at all?
And,
but you fucking can't stand everything that comes out of her mouth.
You got to get rid of this girl.
All right.
It's not going to get any better.
You did it a zillion times.
All right?
You got to go cold Turkey.
You got to cut her off.
All right.
Cause what's going to happen is if you stay with her and then he ended up
fucking feelings for her.
She might fuck you over and you'd have loved it to begin with.
Or you get married to her and then,
then the fucking looks go away and then you just whip this fucking idiot who
can't tell a joke,
can't tell stories and listens to shitty music and eventually a,
you're going to pull a Phil Spector I,
that's what I'm going,
you know your hair's going to be all over the place.
You can stick a gun in her mouth.
There's going to be horrible.
You don't want to do that.
All right.
I would.
Um,
okay.
What is hard though is you're saying she's so good at bed that it makes all the
other girls seem like non alcoholic beer.
Well,
you know,
that's one of the,
that's one of the dangers of going out and living life is a,
okay,
people will never leave their hometown.
They just fucking stay there.
They don't know what the fuck they're missing.
So they can actually,
in a way,
you know,
live a happier existence just by not fucking knowing the fact is now,
you know a level
yeah.
Of A,
of banging that you didn't know before.
Okay.
Jesus Christ.
Yeah.
You know,
uh,
you're in trouble.
No Sir.
I can tell you this,
you know,
just standing outside of it,
listening to it,
you got to get rid of her.
You can't stand or just get rid of it.
You just fucking her.
Eventually those tits are going to fucking sag.
Um,
but that was that mouse still going to work.
Okay.
And when she's not blowing you,
she's going to be telling you awful stories so you know what you need to do.
Um,
so there you go.
I would just man up and get rid of it.
And it's,
it's like,
I don't know,
the longer you get away from it,
you know,
here's a great thing.
You know what
I dunno.
Mixed time.
You fucking rub one out.
Think of her immediately afterwards.
All right.
And that's going to be your true fucking feeling about her.
Facebook messages a day.
Billy,
I need your help dealing with the girlfriend issue.
I have been seeing my lady since December.
I'm 30 and she is 27.
That's a good fucking age difference.
I like it.
She lived in the city and I lived in the country.
We started as a long distance relationship,
but it got serious quickly and now she has moved back home.
Um,
she's,
what is this fucking green acres?
Yeah.
Um,
she is busy buying her own house but has stayed with me for the last two weeks.
We've talked about me moving in with her.
We tell each other I love you and we're making plans for the future,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
So today I log onto my computer in her Facebook page is still logged in.
Oh,
this is a whole new world man.
The Facebook thing,
uh,
me being a curious creep,
I started snooping in the message section.
I find a conversations she's had with former boyfriend on February 1st she tells
the guy,
I still miss your face done.
It's over.
Walk away,
walk away like Deniro and he just fucking get up and walk out.
It's over.
I don't need,
I don't even need to read the rest of this sir.
It is fucking over.
Okay.
But I'll keep reading it just cause I have to fill up an hour here.
But I know you know the people listen and know.
Um,
anyways he goes,
I don't see any response from the guy.
Then on February,
February 11th,
she trolls out another message.
I love how now you're stalking her Facebook page as well.
You should,
you had probable cause you never did know you were,
you were a creep and then you find,
you know what,
this one stand up in court court cause you didn't have a war,
but you know what?
You got instinct and you can't teach that.
Uh,
anyways,
she trolls out another message that say,
hope all is well and again,
no response.
Yeah,
dude,
she's settling for you.
I hate to tell you that,
but she's settling for you.
What she's trying to do is,
is if this mother fucker goes,
you know,
I miss your face too.
She's out.
All right?
But if he doesn't,
he doesn't get back to her.
She's going to settle for you.
Yeah.
Okay.
And I'm not saying you're a bad person,
I'm just saying the feeling isn't there.
She's settling few,
which means the entire time you're fucking marriage,
every time you're not looking at her,
she's just going to be staring at the back of your head,
looking at your dumb shoulders.
Something just going like,
how the fuck did I end up with?
How did I fuck that other one up?
You know,
you don't want to be that.
You got to get somebody as crazy about you.
Anyways,
here we go.
There was some previous,
somewhat explicit messages they sent back and forth before we got together and
messages about how they should text instead of Facebook.
All that being said,
she is good.
Tell.
All that being said,
however,
everybody,
uh,
she is good to me.
I'm good to her and we have fun,
a fun,
loving relationship.
I had solid trust and now I'm very confused.
How should I approach her with this?
I know if I keep it to myself,
it's going to fester and really pissed me off.
Would you head for the hills immediately or give the relationship a chance?
Thanks.
And Go fuck yourself.
This is what I would do.
I would be a hundred percent honest with them.
Say,
listen,
I gotta be honest with you.
Uh,
what the fuck is today?
The 18th,
about a month and a half ago,
I want to use the computer and your Facebook page was open and even though I
shouldn't have looked,
I did look.
And then she's going to start crying and she's going to start fucking,
she's going to turn a fucking cap around backwards and getting your face and
start screaming and yelling.
But blahblahblahblahblah fuck all of that.
Fuck all of that.
She's going to come at you like that cause she knows what's coming.
All right.
And don't get mad.
Don't take the fucking bay.
This is the time,
sir.
You have to hang onto your fucking emotion.
She's going to cry or she's going to yell or she's going to do both cause she
knows what the f how could you do?
Well you didn't trust me anyways in the bed,
the bed,
you know,
and you don't have the line that they have where they just,
female intuition,
they,
they get to hide behind that.
You know,
like,
like guys don't have any fucking instincts.
Like we weren't blessed with any of that.
You know,
fucking chasing down saber tooth tigers were sharpened sticks like we weren't,
we weren't blessed with that.
He sorta instinct,
give me a fucking break.
All right,
so anyway,
she's going to cry or she's going to yell or she's going to do fucking both.
And you just stand there and you let her do it.
All right?
And when she's done yelling and crying or whatever the fuck it is,
just say,
yeah.
And I saw a message that you wrote to an old boyfriend saying,
I still miss your face.
You know,
and then you tried to contact them again on the 11th.
And it's been bugging me and I did want to bring this up to you because I didn't
want to look like a creep and I didn't want to hurt your feelings that I don't
trust you.
But um,
you obviously still have feelings for this person
then I guess you're settling for me.
Like if this guy doesn't get back to you,
then you're going to move forward with and settle for me.
And that's not what I want.
I want someone who's crazy about me.
It doesn't have other issues.
You,
you seem to have unresolved stuff with this guy and um,
you know,
I'm not getting any younger so
and then she,
yeah,
back it up with me,
but bed,
the bed,
all this shit and just keep going.
Listen,
this is a face that you miss,
sweetheart.
Ed,
it's not mine.
You know,
sir,
take your heart and stick it on the fucking nightstand and go into your brain.
All right.
Get some self esteem here.
This is fucking bullshit.
All right.
All that being said.
She's good to me.
She's not good to you.
Not 100%
all right.
I'm telling you.
Get out of it.
Fuck that.
All right.
Did I make myself clear?
Next one,
Ufo.
Dude,
my question is in here somewhere.
Oh,
for fuck's sakes,
I got to read all of this.
Brace yourselves.
Everybody did.
I did.
I tell you guys,
I fucking got on the God damn scale and I'm 185 I was all the way down to 170
lbs.
I've I fucking,
I was too skinny then.
I should have been like [inaudible] 72 that's my fighting weight.
I've put on,
I put on 13 fucking pounds.
I take it you don't,
you know what's the dumbest thing you can do is when you don't want to get on
the scale,
you know,
like I should get on the scale.
Good now don't cause I don't want to know that.
Do you just signing yourself off to another fucking 10 fucking pounds had a
waffle,
which in Wisconsin,
what the fuck was I thinking?
I was on that crack again.
I was hitting the pipe.
I was doing the sugar,
salt,
fucking arm wrestle,
you know,
Chanel,
I gotta I gotta go.
I gotta go run the fucking stairs now.
I did that to myself because I hit a fucking waffle,
which in grand rapids fucking with,
uh,
Michigan
wasn't just a waffle,
which I had McDonald's twice.
You know,
why did I have Mcdonald's?
I Dunno.
I Dunno why I did.
I went drives like,
you know what,
I haven't had one of those in a while and I fucking,
you know,
hit the pipe again.
Had that,
I started drinking Miller high life and a fucking cat.
They had the talls right down the street and it became like this ritual.
I watch a hockey game.
I throw back a tall [inaudible],
hey,
hey man,
be that up to,
next thing you know,
I'm having one a period and then I'm looking down at my stomach and I'm going
like that.
Really?
Come on.
This isn't,
Hey,
I'm all right.
I had a banana for breakfast,
right?
I'm fun,
asshole fucking asshole.
Hey piece of cake yesterday,
it had green frosting.
The fuck is wrong with me.
What am I doing?
You know
what,
what am I going to bottom out?
So I bought him out.
So now I'm back.
I'm down to about a buck 82.
I've dropped like a couple,
two or three pounds and uh,
you know,
uh,
just fucking moron.
You don't,
I'm like,
I'm like Bill Clinton before the heart attack,
up and down,
up and down with the fucking wait.
All right,
you are folks,
dude,
my question is in here somewhere.
I am nowhere near a conspiracy freak or anything like that,
but I do admit,
I get a hard on for any documentary on that secret military base in Nevada that
is called area 51 the government is suppose,
well,
I mean,
believe in aliens like
I have,
like,
I don't know that,
that's really not that crazy.
You know what you,
you think like how big the fucking universities,
that's just life on one planet.
No life anywhere else.
Despite the fact that they see evidence of water on Mars at some point,
you know,
I'm telling you guys would not that special
if you're God and you made the whole university the,
I'm just going to sit back,
watch in one fucking planet.
Maybe that's why the earth is so fucked up.
I don't think he's been watching us for the last couple thousand was the last
time he reached out.
Reach out,
reach out and freak out.
Right?
When's the last time he fucking did that was the last time he fucking was in a
burning Bush going,
hey,
you're there.
You're there with the long fucking curvy stick next to the sheep.
Come over here.
Come over to the burning Bush.
You know,
when's the last time we did that?
I think he's been watching another earth.
I'm flipping through the channels,
you know?
Can you imagine how clear his fucking,
how big do you think God's Flatscreen TV is?
How clear is that picture?
I bet even if you make it to heaven,
you know,
you don't even get to see it.
Like he comes out of his office and he try to peek in real quick and like the
human eye you get just,
it's just too much of a fucking glare.
Right.
Um,
so anyways,
yeah.
If you believe in aliens,
I mean,
I don't know that,
that,
that we can reach one another,
you know,
that whole flying saucer fucking oh shit.
Okay.
I mean,
how long can you go with,
with artificial breathe,
you know,
some sort of atmosphere in there.
I was like on Star Trek,
I mean they just had this limitless supply of fucking oxygen.
Oh,
just fucking flying through space.
Now look at them.
They landed on a lot of planets set at oxygen.
They would just land on these planets and they just had oxygen.
And I think what they did was they opened the day,
landed the star ship enterprise and they just opened the windows and they got
some more oxygen and then they flew away.
Right.
Isn't that how it works?
Anyways?
Uh,
the government supposedly is housing and researching crashed Ufos and uses
deadly force to keep regular people out.
Do you have any opinion on the subject?
I think I just said,
I mean,
I don't,
fuck do I think they actually have the bodies of aliens?
Um,
did you realize like the level of secrecy you would have to have if you actually
had that shit?
That would be like one of the things before they went in the room.
It's like,
okay,
we're going to let you in this room and you got to understand when you go in
this room,
the doors closing and you're never getting out because you're going to see some
fucking shit in here that I don't give a fuck.
You're not.
If you have one shot a Nyquil,
you're,
you're going to be blabbering about it.
Did you can't do it.
So I,
I don't,
I don't know.
I don't fucking know.
Um,
anyways,
he goes,
what is your bullshit meter say?
I think there's way too much of a veil of secrecy around the place to think
otherwise.
I used to know someone who was a career air force pilot.
Whenever the subject of that base or those mysterious for flights,
Smith's series lights over Phoenix scene in 1997 kicking up,
he completely removed himself from the conversation.
Uh,
those mysterious lights,
I don't even know what you're talking about for all,
you know,
that just testing some psycho fucking weaponry.
You know,
early morning the new Yankee stadium came out in like,
oh eight or o nine and they will like,
we have 2013 technology.
All right?
If those fucking morons that run that place can have shit that we're not going
to have,
you know,
they can be four or five years ahead of us.
Can you imagine what the government is?
Okay?
I mean,
they got to have shit from like,
I dunno,
2014 I have no fucking idea.
I don't know.
Anyways,
he says,
quite frankly,
the evenings lapse would end right after the topic was brought up.
I believe in life outside of our universe to think that we human and Oliver's
inhabit.
And so the only life anywhere is just plain ignorant.
I 100% agree with that.
Uh,
I'm sure you've heard stories about President Nixon secretly showing you FO's in
aliens to his favorite comedian Jackie Gleason.
Uhh,
that's a complete crock of shit.
Uh,
what would you like?
He's going to do that.
All right.
Now I'm know I'm not supposed to show you the
Arrow way we call it was a bad Nixon impression right there.
Um,
what would happen if you were shown some stuff like that?
I imagine I would immediately be microchipped or shot in the back of the fucking
head.
Would you tell about it?
I would want to know about that.
That if I actually found out about that,
it would blow my fucking mind.
I,
you know what it is?
Look,
maybe the,
maybe your Air Force Guy Buddy that has seen some,
because I would say that like all converse.
No,
but you know what?
He laughs right up until that moment.
If he wasn't laughing at all throughout all your conversation,
then I would,
I would believe it more because I know if I knew some shit like that.
Yeah.
And then I would sit there and listening to people talking about God and Holy
Shit that we believe down here that didn't include aliens.
I would,
I would feel like a fucking alien cause that would be like,
ah,
yeah,
we're just a speck of dust.
They are people and there's all this other stuff out there.
And uh,
yeah,
I mean it would drive me nuts after awhile.
Um,
yeah,
no,
I'm not cut out for that fucking,
uh,
the kind of secrets I can keep our like,
you know,
it stays in the locker room kind of shit.
You know what I mean?
You live your life or you want to fucking live your life,
you know,
and until like if you're a look,
if you porn shit until the water supply,
you know,
if you're doing stuff like that,
if you fucking vandalizing the neighborhood I live in,
then go fuck yourself.
All right.
But you know,
the other bullshit,
I looked the other way,
but if the,
if I knew there was fucking aliens,
yeah,
no,
look,
I'm too fucking stupid.
There's no way they would tell it to me.
If I was in the air force,
how far to the air force would think I would get?
You think I'd get anywhere beyond the guy with the two sticks guide in the
fucking plane.
And you know,
I don't know.
Anyway,
she says Black Hawks First Bruins for the 2013 Stanley Cup hawks and five,
maybe six.
Uh,
I don't see us making the Stanley Cup finals.
I hate to say that unless we make a trade.
I know we're looking for Alfredson,
but I don't know who we're going to give up for him.
But,
uh,
I saw a gap between us and the,
the Pittsburgh Penguins.
I'd be interested to see how those are some of the other teams.
I'm going to start watching the penguins.
I'm waiting to see when they play the Canadians,
cause I want to see if the Canadians are as good as a record because if fucking
killing it right now,
they really are.
Um,
oh,
by the way,
that almost made me stop Rudy for GSP when the crowd started going Ole,
Ole,
and the only thing that saved me was he had the Quebec Nordiques fucking tattoo
on the back of his cab.
So I'm like,
all right,
this guy fucking,
he likes the avalanche.
All right.
Balinski many times you said we're all doing because of overpopulation,
but it's actually the opposite.
We are doomed because people are not having enough children.
Oh,
Gj
okay.
From a,
Oh,
Jesus.
Did you join a cult,
sir?
All right.
You know what?
I'll,
I'll go along with this.
The following article discusses what I'm talking about.
We'll,
I'll put this link up on the podcast page for everybody to read.
Essentially,
America's fertility rate is declining,
meaning the population will get older and older as it also shrinks,
meaning more healthcare costs and fewer reasons for businesses to innovate and
provide better products.
Also,
global population growth is slowing to a halt and we'll begin to shrink within
60 years.
Uh,
I don't know where you're getting your stats from serve,
but uh,
okay.
Okay.
Low fertility societies don't innovate because their incentives for
consumption's tilt overwhelmingly toward healthcare.
They don't invest aggressively because the average age skewing higher and
capital shifts to preserving their epidemic.
But don't put that,
but apathy,
Sarah,
you would addressing,
are you ever going to address what the environment?
Yeah.
Are you going to address what we've done to the environment or are you one of
those people who believes that 7 billion people on this planet.
Okay.
And that horse shit out there in the Pacific Ocean,
that's fucking two and a half times the size of Texas and two miles deep that's
swirling pile of trash out there.
We put a fucking hole in the ozone layer,
okay?
Less people
as far as for the survival of humanity.
Okay?
Fuck all selling widgets and all of that.
Horseshit and whole.
Everybody's going to be on the iron lung if we don't have any babies.
Um,
a bunch of people need to die.
They need the die off.
There's way too many fucking people.
There's only so much fresh water.
There's only so much natural resources.
There's only so much fish you can pull out of the ocean.
There's only so much fucking shit you can throw in the ocean before.
There's that tipping point,
tipping point.
Um,
what you're sending me,
sir,
is not facts.
What you're sending me as an angle.
This is this guys and I will read this angle,
okay?
But what I love is that someone has written that,
that you know,
um,
overpopulation,
you're like many times you said that we're all doing because of overpopulation,
but it's actually the opposite.
What?
Cause this guy says so.
So the other smart people that read the road,
those other studies,
they're immediately all full of shit because this other guy said this,
you know,
did you read the shit that I read?
Cause I'll read your thing.
But um,
I think the problem is,
is that human beings will never stop believing that we're,
we're fucking important and that we're made in God's image and all that other
fucking ego maniac shit.
Okay.
That eventually causes you to have fucking eight kids and go out and buy two
flat screen fucking TVS.
The solution,
sir,
is not more people.
Okay.
I mean,
think about it.
What,
what,
where are we doomed?
Back in the day,
a thousand years ago,
what was the world population then?
Where are we doomed?
We somehow survived.
How will we not going to survive,
sir?
Because of these healthcare costs.
We have a national debt that we're never going to fucking pay.
We're still all going to work every day.
People still have apples in their mouths when they want them.
I don't understand what the fuck you saying.
The greatest thing that could happen for the possible,
I believe for the survival of humanity is if there was way less of us,
way,
fucking less way,
fucking less.
All right,
and if you somehow were able to weed out sociopath's along the fucking way and
selfish cons,
I think if you just weeded out sociopath's and selfish cons,
you'd have the right number on this planet
and I think it would be under seven figures.
Whatever,
sir,
I'm just fucking with you.
I'll,
I'll read your,
your,
I read your shit.
You know,
but don't come at me like you fucking know what you're talking about any more
than I do cause you read some stupid article.
All right.
Um,
I love how it's all based around business.
Low fertility societies don't innovate because their incentives for
consumption's tilt overwhelmingly towards health care.
Uh,
I don't,
I just in philosophy,
I just believe in it whatsoever.
All right?
But I am a moron,
but I think I'm smarter than you because I could admit that.
All right,
that's the podcast for this week.
Everybody.
Uh,
as always,
if you'd like to donate to this podcast,
just go to the Amazon link on my podcast page,
Bill bird.com.
Click on the podcast page.
You just click on the Amazon link.
If you want to buy something,
it'll take you right to Amazon.
Doesn't add any money.
They kicked me a little bit of money for whatever you buy.
And then I'd take the 10% of that and I sent it on to the wounded warriors
project.
And,
uh,
and that's it.
That's the podcast for this week.
Go fuck yourselves.
And I will law hopefully this time next week I will find myself,
uh,
somebody knows how to put together my house the way it used to be.
If anybody lives in the Los Angeles area and has lived through this shit and
wanting to restore the wood and everything to the way it was,
and you know,
no of a contractor is somebody,
please,
uh,
send me an email bill@themmpodcast.com.
Look me up on Twitter,
Facebook,
anything.
Reach out to me.
I,
I'm,
I'm open to all suggestions and I really appreciate everybody who's helped me so
far to steer me in the right direction.
It means a lot to me.
All right.
Go fuck yourselves.
We'll talk to you next week.